l'union européenne et le royaume uni
espère arracher un accord post break
site dans les prochains jours les
négociateurs européens michel barnier et
britannique david frost ont repris les
discussions ce week end
il tente de dissiper l'épais brouillard
qui entoure l'avenir de la relation
entre londres et bruxelles
et le temps presse la période de
transition permettant de conclure un
accord de libre-échange approche à
grands pas sans traité commercial d'ici
le 1er janvier prochain les échanges
entre les vingt-sept et le royaume uni
se ferait selon les règles de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
synonyme donc de quotas et de droits de
douane les deux camps court le risque
d'un nouveau choc économique
au centre de ce bras de fer entre
londres et bruxelles qui dure maintenant
depuis 9 mois
l'accès des pêcheurs européens aux zones
britannique
il ne peut y avoir d'accord s'il n'y a
pas un accord satisfaisant qui donne un
accès durable et large aux eaux
britanniques l'absence d'accord ou un
mauvais accord sur la pêche aurait un
rebond sur toutes les politiques de
pêche en europe
remettant en cause un équilibre
patiemment conçu nous avons quelques
jours encore beaucoup de chemin à
parcourir
et si le royaume uni croit que la
question du temps joue en sa faveur
ça n'est pas le cas le négociateur
européen serait en revanche prêt à faire
quelques concessions
selon des sources européennes michel
barnier aurait notamment proposé que lui
restitue 15 à 18% du total des quotas
européens pêcher dans les eaux
britanniques
une proposition qui ne semble pas
convaincre londres pour le ministre
britannique des affaires étrangères
dominique rab la pêche reste je cite une
pomme de discorde majeure dans les
discussions poste bruch site
l'incertitude plane donc plus que jamais
le déblocage finale se fait toujours
attendre
les négociateurs vont en tout cas devoir
conclure un accord suffisamment tôt pour
permettre sa ratification par le royaume
uni mais aussi par le parlement européen
qui tiendra sa prochaine séance plénière
à la mi décembre